high for the day today 67 degrees 45
overnight for the low and this is where
we should be
for this time of year right at 67. the
record on this date believe it or not we
hit 84 degrees
on way back in 1972. now onto some
neighborhoods
let's start off in the northwest part of
the valley centennial hills at 66
62 for summerlin 66 also for the lakes
downtown north las vegas also double 60
69 for sunrise mountain and 68 for green
valley
66 roads ranch and mountains edge for
you nice out there and comfortable
68 for henderson if you like these
temperatures and you want it more
comfortable
we got a treat for tomorrow for sure 68
for prompt boulder city 66 and death
valley
73 while laflin you're coming in right
now at 72 degrees here's our radar
network
we had some echoes on the radar and just
some sprinkles in some spots of town
yesterday but that was it now all that's
moving off towards east look at that
snow showers that's where we want the
snow
the western side of the rockies to help
feed lake mead but that energy all
moving off
into the plains states meanwhile that
next system right here in the pipeline
is going to increase our winds not
tomorrow so tomorrow looks good
this is saturday now where we'll see
breezy winds return
sunday we'll see clouds behind that but
not really expecting much wind on sunday
not expecting any rain either but then
we see this one crawl down and up and
over
on wednesday we have slight chances of
showers to return
but unfortunately we'll also see some
wind along with that too so
gusty winds on saturday stronger winds
although we think now will be on monday
and tuesday with windy conditions and
breezy winds behind that
by midweek and also on thursday so
here's your forecast 47 overnight chilly
and clear overnight we're right where we
should be for overnight low but our
daytime highs are going to be nice and
mild
73 degrees perfect too because we should
be at 68.
this is very comfortable for tomorrow
and also your winds stay light
highs across the valley for tomorrow
lots of 70's here 72 for north las vegas
spring valley mountains edge
aleonte 71 centennial hills 70 for
summerlin and 71 for henderson
outside the valley we'll also see those
70s in front and boulder city loudly
at 82. now on to our eight day forecast
shall we
breezy on saturday look at those numbers
in the 70s and a huge
temperature drop by tuesday look at that
73 to 64.
there's those shower chances by midweek
that's your most accurate forecast brian
all yours ted thank you